Laura wrote in and said hey are there
questions about the show or in general
that you hate answering yet one that
comes to mind is I'll meet someone okay
and they asked me what I do and I say oh
I have a syndicated radio and television
program that's on 200 terrestrial radio
and television stations across the
country and it's on iTunes as well as
YouTube and iheartradio and blah blah
blah blah blah and after I say that they
say also it's like an online only thing
and usually I just repeat in the exact
same tone as if i had never already
explained as a no I have a syndicated
program that is on two hundred radio and
television stations and I think for
whatever reason people just can't
conceive of the fact that this could be
an actual broadcast show I don't think
that it's that people don't listen I
think it just doesn't compute when they
say Oh what do you do and they see me
and make whatever judgments they make
based on whatever my physical appearance
or my casual nature whatever and I say
it's a nationally syndicated program in
200 stations I just don't think it
computes they're like oh wait what
broadcast are you online only right they
just assume that's what it must be yeah
they assume you're are a youtuber right
arm which is a a term that is often used
as a derogatory term yes it is and it
has been against us as well although I
what's wrong with being on YouTube that
nothing's wrong with being on YouTube
but it depends what you're doing on
YouTube oh sure yeah the other one
that's a common one is when I tell
people well when I tell people I'm from
Argentina it actually opens up usually
it's a few different lines of
questioning all of which are insanely
frustrating at this point when I've had
to answer these questions a thousand
times I say oh I'm actually from
Argentina English is my second language
I grew up speaking Spanish blah blah
blah and then the question is also do
you speak Portuguese now I know when
someone asks me that that what they mean
is I understand Portuguese to be the
language of Argentina so that's why I'm
asking you I like to sometimes because
I've answered this question million
times pretend that they're asking me
this question knowing that in Argentina
you speak spanish as I've often recently
said so I'll just play it cool and say
uh no
I don't and not actually explain because
that's not the language of Argentina and
let people just stew in their own uh
ignorance around that one but sometimes
I will say no because that's not the
language that we speak in Argentina
that's one I've answer that you know
must be a thousand times at this point
the other one is wait uh how are you
Argentinian and speak Spanish because
you're white at which point I'll take a
couple of approaches sometimes it's well
you know that in Spain that one of the
primary uh colonial cut-up colonizing
countries of the latin american spanish
speaking world many people are white in
Spain you know that right or I'll say
yeah Argentina is like eighty-five
percent white it's mostly European and
you know white people can speak Spanish
too in many countries have white people
including Mexico Colombia whatever at
this point it's just so tired and I get
that if something someone else is asking
me they're not doing it out of malice or
because 999 other people have asked me
but it is amazing just how how common
the same questions come up when I
explain to people on from Argentina do
you find that at first you found the
questions to be a bit jarring and then
you got annoyed with the questions but
then you reach a point where you just
think it's funny basically yeah that's
usually the way went well at first it
was I I found them confusing where
people would say oh wow look even when I
was 12 so what is it it must be tropical
an Argentine a year-round right because
it's south of us and then I explain at
12 to adults will actually no you know
what matters is how far from the equator
you are and if you're 2,000 miles north
of the equator and 2,000 miles south of
the Equator generally speaking adjusting
of course for whether you're near a body
of water or altitude or whatever else
jet stream you're going to have similar
weather so in the same way that
Philadelphia at the same distance north
of the Equator that philadelphia is is
the distance south of the Equator that
way no situs is so although it doesn't
snow because of the particular weather
patterns it actually gets quite cold in
winter and yes there's electricity and
internet access or whatever um but yeah
now I just sort of assume people have
all these misconceptions and it doesn't
really rub me the wrong way anymore I
just sort of feel bad that that people
are just this clueless still yeah I
don't really have to feel questions like
that the same way you do
luckily